[Musique]
et bien notre chose qui annonce sur une
carte de Bretagne
niché au fond de l'estuaire du jeudi ce
qui en fait un peu abrité est très lié à
une trentaine de kilomètres au nord de
Guingamp et la capitale du Trégor riche
de culture maraîchères d'agriculture et
de pêche comme de beauté touristiques et
d'un prestigieux passé
attachant Tréguer l'état bien des titres
par ces petites rues charmantes et les
belles façades des maisons anciennes par
l'esprit et la gentillesse des Trégor
rois chanté par les luzels le gofik
Vertou à l'atoll le bras ce qu'elle
vient à nous attachant aussi par la
douceur d'y vivre
la chérie est bonne tenue à l'ombre de
la flèche de la basilique cathédrale non
loin de ce cloître merveilleux
l'ancien évêché aux pierres vénérables
est devenu l'Hôtel de la Tour d'astings
[Musique]
les autres sont d'origine Douarnenez
natale nous la retrouverons dans
quelques instants elle ne quitte guère
c'est pour nous lui René Darchen cache
derrière un abord bourru un cœur
excellent et un joyeux caractère
il le laisse à personne le soin de faire
le marché c'est dit-il la tâche première
d'un bon hôtelier
à moins que ce soit une façon de
dissimuler le plaisir qui lui prend
lui-même
ça va
en retard
penser aux gens de Saint-Brieuc qui
viennent déguster le homard
pensez tout à l'heure à la pièce de
contrefaits
pour cet après-midi et ce soir ou demain
matin
tout a son importance dans un marché
de banane 5 kg de citron 5
[Musique]
quant à lui qui renonce qui ajoutait en
cuisine
la simplicité et le signe de la
perfection le curlons ce qui qui
écrivait encore au soir de sa vie voilà
50 ans que je crie sur tous les toits
que la Bretagne est une admirable région
gastronomique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à faire la maison à midi
cafards est une recette difficile à
réaliser oh non monsieur du tout elle
est très facile à faire mais seulement
ça s'accompagne beaucoup de légumes et
dans le trigo ici nous en trouve donc
beaucoup nous sommes dans le pays des
légumes frais d'ailleurs et pomme de
terre surtout ça on en trouve mais
couramment tous les jours
si vous voulez un kick à farce de 6/8
personnes disons il nous faut du boeuf
d'abord dans les deux kilos
l'os à moelle
les jarrets de porc ça l'est toujours
et un morceau de là aussi toujours salé
ensuite un peu de saucisson
appréciable
je vois là-bas que vous avez des légumes
mais oui nous avons toujours des légumes
pour frais ici à trier un beau chou tout
blanc tout frais de ce matin
poireaux oignons
vous mettez à peu près 1 kg 2 kg de
carottes nous oignons 4 ou 5 aussi et un
paquet de poireaux et puis alors je vois
également des pommes de terre c'est pour
après ça se cuit dans un petit filet
qu'on met dans le pot-au-feu et qu'on
retire au dernier moment pour
accompagner tout s'est bien
il y a encore beaucoup de choses sur la
table ah tout ça mais tout ça c'est pour
le phare oui alors là c'est une tâche
plus délicate de quoi s'agit-il là
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut pour les
phares pour les phares il nous faut je
fais un phare sucré
et un fard salé
alors dans le phare salé je mets mes
pruneaux on le sale un peu avec un tout
petit
et ensuite vous mettez un quart de lait
et un quart de pot-au-feu du bouillon de
pot-au-feu
je pense qu'il vous faut du sel du
poivre
je n'en ai pas rien du sel et puis un
peu de beurre
[Musique]
150 g
je pense que nous avons à peu près vu
tout ce qui nous fallait ah oui mais
seulement le phare c'est pour après
alors nous allons pouvoir commencer la
fabrication de notre petit cafards ah
oui là tout de suite
de la marmite je suppose
de la main mais il nous faut une très
grande celui qui a une antenne c'est
peut-être mieux mais enfin moi je me
sers toujours de ma grande casserole ici
je commence par mettre la viande
le boeuf d'abord
le jarret ça c'est pour après ça
et voilà voilà
je vais le faire blanchir tout de suite
on le met dans le pot-au-feu avant de
servir
voilà la première opération va donc se
trouver réalisée et alors maintenant
qu'est-ce que nous allons faire
nous allons faire le phare le phare en
fait les phares si j'ai bien compris
mais oui monsieur parce que le blanc et
le noir alors comment s'y prendre voilà
[Musique]
une liste de farine
[Applaudissements]
blanche ensuite 4 cuillerées de sucre
je remets un peu
comme une pâte à crêpes si j'ose dire
c'est la vraie pâte à crêpes mais un peu
plus lourdes
très important il faut pas qu'il y ait
de grumeaux
on a vu une crêperie
alors vous avez gardé le bon tour de
main là
les raisins
deuxième opération alors maintenant le
phare noir on s'y prendre la même façon
pareil mais seulement avec un peu de
bouillon
en fait alors tout à l'heure nos invités
ou pour les gousses salées
alors dans ce cas on ajoute pas d'oeuf
non pas dans celle-ci
crapette c'est à dire qu'il pouvait on
arrivait à l'émier on les niait
mais moi je n'ai jamais fait non plus
alors tout de même quelque chose
m'intrigue maintenant parce que je vois
que vos deux passes sont préparés alors
je me demande comment on va pouvoir les
introduire dans notre soupe
oh mais il y a les poches
dans le potage
et une heure de cuisson
alors
nous sommes prêts
[Musique]
alors voilà donc le fameux sac ah non on
dit ça le vrai nom c'est ça d'ailleurs
il a une petite histoire ce sac de phare
dans le temps l'ancien temps pour une
demande en mariage le jeune homme
allait faire sa demande très tard le
soir la jeune fille l'attendait couchée
dans un lit clos
les portes tirées le jeune homme frappé
à une de ses portes elle ouvrait
alors le jeune homme tenait dans sa main
un sac exactement comme celui-ci le
fameux farsat et si la jeune fille
acceptait
l'affaire était conclue et si elle
refusait les fiançailles il n'y avait
pas lieu donc cette expression de bien
de là rendre son sac expression qui est
encore employé aujourd'hui je crois
quand on remette pour le remerciement
d'un ouvrier
de trouver cette tradition en Bretagne
ce mot en fait en tout cas en ce qui
concerne ce sac d'aujourd'hui là il
n'ira on ne va pas le rendre on va le
rendre à personne on va le mettre dans
dans le pot de souple ah pas tout de
suite il y a encore les jarret à mettre
l'avant
et puis alors le chou peut-être
également qu'il restait quelque chose
ensuite on le met avec le phare en même
temps que le phare alors on a encore
combien de temps de cuisson maintenant
le temps de cuisson il faut compter pour
le phare trois quarts d'heure pour le
phare blanc
heure
deuxième opération maintenant
parce que
la farine de blé noir
dans un moment alors il est vrai
encore une heure atteinte alors
qu'est-ce qui reste maintenant il y a
les sacs
ainsi successivement vont ajouter les
différents éléments qui manquent encore
à la potée à 19h les jarrets y en
trouver leur place peu avant 20h madame
darchêne ajouté les sacs à faire d'abord
le phare noir comme nous l'a dit Rosa
qui demande un peu plus de cuisson puis
le blanc
nous ne dînerons qu'à cet art qu'importe
il n'est pas bon de se précipiter à
table
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 20h40 les finitions chou et saucisses
il est maintenant 21h
l'heure est venue de démouler les sacs
et de découvrir les boules chaudes et
odorantes qui sont probablement les
ancêtres du pudding anglais
[Musique]
les viandes découpées
le plat garni dressé avec soin devient
coloré fumant somptueux
[Musique]
il y a longtemps il y a longtemps qu'il
me réclame
[Musique]
alors le kikafarce plat traditionnel
breton est assurément un plat sans
fausse prétention
mais que l'on ski encore lui ne
disait-il pas ce qu'on fait
la cuisine bretonne est simple
scène loyale et droite comme les Bretons
eux-mêmes
[Musique]